[music]
We tear Ukraine out of the night But in terms of the
area,
even less than 100,000 people are alive in all
areas up to the Russian
tens of thousands
80 places and forces under water man-made
environmentally friendly disaster in
Europe
[music]
here we can already unequivocally
state that we are talking about a deliberate
sabotage by the Ukrainian side  this sabotage
could potentially have
consequences for several tens of
thousands of residents of the region
environmental consequences and consequences of a
different nature that have yet to be
established Apparently, the version is
also connected with the fact that, having launched
offensive operations two days ago,
now the Ukrainian armed forces are not
achieving their goals,
offensive operations are choking
at the same time, you can explain the reason for such
behavior, you can simply have a saying in
Ukraine,
that is, we can’t do anything But we’ll do
harm, we’ll spoil, first of all,
threats of food humanitarian
aid,
you know that good Lord, we will never
die of hunger because
all of Russia is with us now This is the first Second
Distract attention  from their terrible
defeats yesterday
[music]